[Music]
and on and off news that's like my life
switch that's a fact
submitted by basic BH yeah a new study
says getting back together with your ex
may be bad for your health
oh really why what happened what's so
bad about that it depends how depends on
how you guys broke up at what age what
if my ex is like a nutritionist ooh
in your face can it be really healthy
for fitness coach or physical therapist
I'd be very healthy massage therapist so
prostitutes here we're talking about
here is relationship cycling so people
that are on and off again thank you
bringing up oh god I hate those
relationships dude because I'm I talk so
much [ __ ] about the other person for
them they get back together so awkward
for me I've learned
look I don't take sighs a friend to well
it's cause like I'm friends with one
really and then there's the other one
I'm my tattoo man first of all dude
I never [ __ ] like yeah sushi suck
[ __ ] suck ass I've done that [ __ ]
her breath smell [ __ ] that [ __ ] hey
we're back together you know what dude
actually what happened was you feel like
you got your back static right yeah yeah
I feel betrayed
you're not backing you up dude this is
the first time you held his tongue ever
watch this man so usually you just edit
that [ __ ] out and Rhys a him but he's
like that thing sucks ass you know so
funny though the other day I just
recorded a vlog in a vice plot which I
haven't done in a while right but after
I recorded I just realized the person
that was asking for advice I just
roasted him for it to eight minutes and
I was like this doesn't help him at all
it doesn't I'm still going to post it
though yeah cuz it's hilarious sometimes
people need roasting to get better in
life because the question that he asked
was he goes how do I get a cute girl I
was like well I looked at his facebook
profile I was like it's kind of hard for
you bro cuz he looked like trash and I
was like how do you how dare you ask for
somebody else to be attractive when you
don't even put the same working for
yourself yeah if your eyebrows connect
all the way across you're gonna have low
chances of you yeah and you don't shower
for a week and you got [ __ ] really
bad gums cuz you don't brush your teeth
what if there
there then it's trying to get some bear
[ __ ] no like if he has the unibrow
you try to a bear yes I like that
alright so this is what they're seeing
here is that when you are in a pattern
of breaking up and getting back together
with the same person relationship
cycling that is linked to higher levels
of anxiety and depression heart failure
from which side books also there your
pride in high school it sounds like some
type of side effect to a diarrhea Drive
or something let me tell you about the
theory of relativity
[Laughter]
nothing shaking him up I would I mean
better health I can see that yeah you're
always in the state of panic
psychological distress yeah yeah you've
been just breaking up with someone
already it's gonna be tough right with
them doing that again and again and
again that takes a toll on you not only
that but then there are reasons why
you're breaking up with this person and
that you forget when you're when you're
getting back together with them and then
you just put yourself through that thing
over and over and over again you always
you're trying to tell yourself that
things are gonna change but they never
do and a lot of these relationships
there's also a lot of psychological
damage like violence or abuse like a lot
of different types of abuse that are
happening here and so obviously people
that are in those relationships they
should just like walk away I hate
fighting I hate fighting with their
significant other so much because it
just drains your [ __ ] life force and
you can't get anything done
I know ever like it just [ __ ] sucks
your [ __ ] spirit out it's so hot know
what you mean I mean I feel like
fighting is good to certain extent cuz
you work through your problems when
you're fighting well why can't you just
talk normally without being hurtful I
mean you don't have to be careful who
said yes fighting is her foal it depends
if you can't control her you're saying
then that discussion is different
about controlling the emotion I think
there's one logical person that can
control the emotion then it's just one
person yelling and I overtime I can like
get resolved that way because it's
really about I think if you lose your
[ __ ]
it just shows I mean no one's winning at
that point you guys both do it where
it's I I don't I feel like it's it sucks
easier to talk at least for us yeah it's
easier to talk if you don't break stuff
I think we're really good at having like
one person doing it also knows no too
crazy you know it's actually I mean I'm
pretty I don't know because she
emotionally break stuff and then I
logically break stuff mm-hmm
so she gets emotionally angry and I get
logically angry mmm but we're still both
have to do this thing where it's like
it's very important that you can't push
me to that point cuz I'm really trying
to be solid here so if I get to that
point I'm gonna have to walk out cuz I
don't like that sighs that's good and
that's also to like I actually believe
that like if you have control of your
emotions then it's actually you're gonna
have a longevity probably anything cuz
it's easier like if you feel yourself
getting heated you can control to calm
down you start not saying things you
don't really don't think I have control
over my emotions are trying oh my god
believe it you can't it's not about
controlling your emotions it's about
controlling your reaction to your
emotions like yeah you can be angry and
stuff but it's not about controlling the
anger it's not about suppression it's
not about your not suppressing the
feeling it's more like expressing it in
a better constructive way it could be
angry but you gotta be able to like
express it in a way where people feel
sad for you and want to help you versus
like most of us get angry and then annoy
the [ __ ] out of everybody yeah you don't
have to you could leave the TV alone
doesn't have to be on the floor shatter
into pieces yeah TV's not on unless it's
like a Sony yeah yeah [ __ ] that company
they were good Oh
Samsung all the way also - there's
probably a difference in like clarity
right if like I feel like if it's you
already know it's gonna be infinite I
bet you're not about the TV quality
like if you know it's like a plasma it's
not like I don't like the relationship I
think that's where the confusion comes
in right because that's why arguments
happen because it's like there's not on
the same page and the clarity is gone if
you already clear that's gonna be
impudent and a little thing is probably
not big that big you would think so
right you would think so
all right that's what helps Muriel and I
got into our first like big like
argument in a very long time and the
reason why it happened was
miscommunication and we were both just
[ __ ] stressed the [ __ ] out because I
had so much to do so much on my [ __ ]
plate and she's just been [ __ ]
working so much but one little
miscommunication was just that little
box that just was gonna set off and then
boom just yelling [ __ ] match over the
phone and it was so funny too because I
was on the freeway and I could just
scream and after we got done with the
screaming match I realized I bet you I
must somebody's [ __ ] snapchat because
I'm literally in the car we're driving
the testicle I was driving the Honda
Element Oh everybody can hear everything
that thing's a tin can you know like
yelling at the top of my head on
Bluetooth are you talking to the phone
oh no it was it was hooked up to the to
the [ __ ] audio that you're hurt yeah
and so we're just arguing back and forth
and I just afterwards I was like oh [ __ ]
I think we just argued over nothing you
knows dope though is the passion behind
it is for the right reason all for sure
a phone it's just how attack like once
you stop caring and you don't get you
need more mins I'm gonna keep saying
passionate passion is good passionate to
it I'm so passionate a different
application I'm very very passionate
yeah I just like I just said just like
it's uh sucks cuz I remember when we
were first going out we argued about
everything and I hated that [ __ ] I
[ __ ] hated it dude I hate it was like
scared that every time I saw her we were
gonna get into a [ __ ] fight and
that's what I got scared of and then
when we started communicating better it
just happens every now and then which is
just normal just because we're two
different people that's all you know but
now I just want to yell anymore cuz it
ruins my my singing voice have you guys
our relationship relationship cycling no
no no wait what number does it like okay
we're done oh let's get back together
we're done get back together the two is
a three plus I had
ever done that if I broke up it's I've
never gotten back with them it's like
this you see this little shrimp chip you
know once you do this can you really put
it back together where it looks the same
absolutely not I [ __ ] destroy that
[ __ ] you kill them walk out of my life
you know what's crazy is I felt that
same way too until until Beth and I
think it was like cuz we're I feel like
we're stronger than ever did you guys
have a very normal like a good breakup
though like it was an understanding of
where you two are at and you guys yeah
it was to the point of like it there
wasn't clarity of which someone was
ready for the long road well see that's
different see for me it was like breakup
for like this get out of my life but
don't you miss that [ __ ] doll pussy's a
buddy dude that's messed up dude as a
dude Wow yeah I know come on I sometimes
it's a very tiny [ __ ] if enough time
was spent and I'm like I forget all the
negativity I go me oh that snake was so
sweet it's that's another thing too is
that you kind of need that drop to make
the highs even better right because if
you have no drop then you don't really
know how highs your highs can be yeah
it's like yeah it's good to see because
sometimes you know like you take time
apart and you realize how much you mean
to each other if it's a healthy
relationship and then you guys can work
through that but yeah they're saying
here relationship cycling is not a good
I think cause a bad habit I think it
depends on like are you the type of
couple that just [ __ ] gets everybody
involved and then you [ __ ] say that's
it forever and then you break up for
like two weeks and you get back together
and in three months you repeat it again
and you keep doing that over and over
different is that I think that's what
they're talking about yeah yeah I think
everyone like argues and fights and does
stupid [ __ ] and and once in a while you
know you do have examples of people
breaking up like in high school and then
they they don't see each other in like
four or five years and then they come
back and then they get married and
they're like you know what it was
actually good so there's a there's so
many examples you can't really make a
blanket statement and say like that's
that's all bad
[Music]